today marks the 15th anniversary of the
hit ballroom breakout it was
nerve-racking
it was scary it was lying I think the
first thing I said I fully got a little
heavy like stumping I think you could
work on that a bit okay all right 13
million people tuned in for the premiere
there were only six celebs including New
Kids on the Block Joey McIntyre and the
first ever Bachelorette Trista Sutter
season one that was the most
controversial season ever
when Kelly Monaco won over John O'Hurley
because John O'Hurley had done so well
consistently and was a consistently
better dancer
I didn't choose me to be the winner so
you won I want 28 seasons 46 pros and
320 contestants later a lot of drama has
gone down on the dance floor
everybody on that balcony has been dying
okay the most memorable moment was when
Marie Osmond fainted
of course you've got to show the Gaiety
and the fun of the Sun I was like what
just happened it was so scary some
celebs you might not remember competed
on the show Kim K her brother Rob Billy
Ray Cyrus Pamela Anderson Kristin
Cavallari and Tonya Harding when I had
got that call like no sir cryin in
season two we met some of our favorite
pros max had long hair Cheryl's was
short and she won the mirror ball Jew
did a great job I had complete
confidence in him I knew he was a
performer from the start
julianne hough joined as a pro and one
season for Kevin how you doing
in season eight her real-life boyfriend
country singer Chuck wicks was cast as
her partner here's the deal I have no
unfair advantage Julian's brother
Derrick had a showmance with actor
Shannon Elizabeth and before max and
PETA got married he was engaged to
another pro Karina Smirnoff the arena's
beautiful I was very very surprised what
can you tell us about the show's [ __ ]
effin Utley picked up and we're super
excited for season 29 so hopefully we're
coming back in the ball yeah that's plan
and yeah I think it's it's a bit of a
challenge if you don't adapt you can't
survive
[Music]